since the dawn of man meat has been
on the menu then a pure beef hamburger
over a pound of meat
and even with growing trends of
vegetarian diets and plant-based
substitutes
around 89 of the world population
consider themselves omnivores
we have come a long way from our hunter
and gatherer roads
we have managed to establish a whole
industry
designed to feed almost 7.7 billion
people
we've maximized production and we
managed to reduce
hunger over the past couple of decades
and although we've become exceedingly
efficient at putting meat on the table
raising livestock animals by the
billions comes with its own set of
consequences
if animal agriculture continues to
expand the way it has
there is a risk that we won't be able to
stop climate change
but with rapid advances in technology we
might soon see a food industry that
leaves all those problems behind
[Music]
i'm about to be one of the world's first
commercial customers
for lab-grown meat cultured meat eat
just as the company and
i'm very very excited
here is the chicken looks pretty crispy
outside
[Music]
that's really good i mean look it's
really tasty
here at 1880 in singapore cultured
chicken is being served under a
regulatory approval granted by the
singaporean government
it's the very first time a cultured meat
product meat made from animal cells
grown in a lab
has been approved for commercial sale
eat just the company behind these
chicken nugget style dishes
is based out of san francisco and got
their start in 2011 developing
plant-based egg substitutes like mung
bean scrambled eggs and mayonnaise
but it wasn't until 2017 that they
announced they were shifting focus to a
cultured meat product
in order to feed the world that we live
in a lot to animal protein
we need to take a third today and it'll
be more tomorrow
of our world and make it dedicated to
feeding chickens and cows
we go to areas that are filled with
biodiverse rainforests
taking a bulldozer to them and planting
soy and corn
to feed the chickens that we eat climate
change is accelerated by the kind of
animal production that we engage in
when we bring animals in tiny little
spaces it accelerates the probability
that more zoonotic diseases
are going to impact our families and
from a morality perspective
why do we need to cause any harm to any
other living thing
to have dinner that tastes good it does
not have to be that way
and those things underlie the force of
this idea
the meat alternatives that have made it
to the market thus far have been
plant-based
imitation beef and pork made from
ingredients like pea protein and coconut
oil by companies like beyond meat and
impossible foods
that's a very different proposition from
cultured meat which is made from actual
animal cells
i'm a huge fan of any company of any
person
trying to make a product that's
improving the food system including all
the plant-based proteins
maybe in some future menu you'll have
this kind of cultivated chicken
and you'll also have a plant-based
version that's fine but i guess you have
to ask yourself
in our lifetime is that diner likely to
also remove the conventional option on
the menu
too we do think we need a more permanent
solution we do think we sort of need
if you will an end game to this problem
and we just think this is more likely to
be
the path to achieve that
so animal cell technology has been
around for several decades
for applications such as development of
vaccines and other biotherapeutics
the first known prototype of cultured
meat
was done by mark post earlier in 2011
and essentially he was developing a beef
patty
it was a very expensive prototype if i'm
not mistaking
above 250 000 euros at the time to
produce just one beef body
it was more of proof of concept to
really demonstrate that
this technology is possible and that it
can be done the way that we
grow and produce cultured chicken is
essentially
we isolate chicken cells from chickens
without having to kill them
so from a small biopsy for instance
we immerse these cells in a liquid broth
that contains the nutrients that the
cells need to survive
and be healthy and to grow we really
need these cells to multiply to reach
the numbers that are sufficient to make
a meat product we're looking into the
cells that are really important for
meat so we think about muscle cells fat
cells
by that isolation we are able to form
those
muscle tissues in culture
the culture happens inside of a
fermentation
tank what we call the bioreactor which
is essentially
providing the same conditions as the
animal body
warm temperatures some sort of
mechanical stimulation
so that the cells are exposed to very
similar conditions that they
have inside of the animal after the
cells proliferate and reach a certain
density
the final step is essentially to
separate
those cells from the liquid broth that
they are in
we just make sure that the product meets
our quality and safety
standards and then those cells are ready
for consumption
milk cheese yogurt a lot of those
derived from fermentations
the only difference is that they are
starting from a different cell type
in this case we're just using the animal
cells as the initial
and beginning of the product
eat just has developed chicken nuggets
so far with far more textured chicken
breasts planned for the future
but another cell-based meat start-up
memphis meats has already started
working on culturing other animal cells
as well we've done beef
we've done duck we've done chicken and
and these are things that are favorites
in various parts of the world for
instance you know people
in america love beef and chicken people
in china
love ducks so we wanted to show that we
at memphis meats can produce
meats that we as a global population
love to eat
there's a lot of similarity in how we
grow the meats from various animals or
fish
but they're also different because the
nutrients they need and how they
actually
come together to form the final product
the meat and i think it's very similar
to how we also grow various animals
there's
uh similarities in the feed that we gave
cows and pigs and chickens
but there's also differences how we
cultivate and it's very similar for us
as well
so we've been working with the fda and
the usda for the last three years
and really developing the guidelines on
how this food should be regulated when
we come to the market
as soon as we get regulatory approval in
the united states
people will be able to go to the
supermarket and buy it and enjoy it
they'll be able to go to a restaurant
near them and order meat directly from
animal sales
but it's not just getting the meat right
once approved the gates open to a very
high potential demand
and scaling becomes the next big hurdle
before we can only make chicken for
myself
my friends my girlfriend my family my
colleagues
now we actually have the ability to make
chicken for millions of people
so that allows us to invest and to allow
the economies of scale to drop the price
the second is we need to reduce the cost
of the nutrients that these cells are
consuming
so i think chicken feed raises or drops
the price of chicken
the nutrients we feed ourselves does the
same thing so we need to drive that down
the cell density is another technical
element we need to continue to
to increase that and hammering on those
things over the course of the next five
uh 10 15 years will put us in a place
where we're significantly below the cost
of this animal protein and that will be
one of the main inflection points that
will
lead to a new way of eating meat
so here is a close-up of
a half-eaten crispy chicken bite
you know what what i'm really thinking
is
i'm just i'm eating chicken i like
chicken
you know the normal chickens i eat i
don't know where they came from
and so i don't know why i should be very
stressed where this came from either
the meat market is worth more than one
trillion dollars annually
and there are over 60 startups in the
cultured meat field
cultured meat has attracted several
prominent investors
including sergey brin richard branson
and bill gates what is also interesting
is that even meet
giants such as cargill and tyson
have invested in space it's this
disruptive potential
of the the market as well
as the promise to greatly reduce the
climate impact of meat production
that has attracted investors
it remains to be seen who will get
regulatory approval in which countries
and whether consumers will like lab grow
meat enough to make the switch
and while there's no evidence that lab
grow meat is any less healthy than
traditional meat there's an ongoing
debate over how healthy eating meat is
in general but if these products are a
success
they could be the beginning of a more
humane less destructive meat industry
the food and ag industry is the most
innovative industry in the world
it's always figured out how to feed a
growing population and we've never
failed doing so
and it's been very clear to us that we
are part of that and we're going to
figure out how to feed the next three
billion people joining us
and i just see an evolution we can do
this a bit differently
we can do this in a way that is
consistent with the kind of people that
we want to be
the kind of planet that we all want to
live in we can build a food system that
reflects really the best
characteristics of who we are and that
makes me really hopeful
you